A lot of different countries have their own unique culture...
...where people get together to wash.
Korea is well known for its communal bathing culture,...
...and if you don't mind being asked this question,...
...could you tell me whether or not you have experienced...
...Korean public bathhouses or saunas?
It's okay, I have actually.
At first, I had a hard time going into the place,...
...but after all, I figure people get really close to each other once they go to public bathhouses together.
How can I express my feelings,...
...with your naked body, you show "nothing but the truth."
In fact, there are many other countries that are famous for their bathing culture.
Finland is the home of the sauna,...
...a small room or house designed as a place to experience dry or wet heat sessions.
And swimsuits, towels, or any other garments are rarely worn in the sauna.
I've heard about that too.
In addition, the Russians are definitely famous for their unique bathing culture...
...and their traditional steam bath is called "Banya."
In Russia, after the first good sweat is induced,...
...it is customary to cool off in the breeze outdoors,...
...or splash with cold water or in a lake or river.
Doesn't that sound cold?
Sometimes, I think going to public bathhouses is the ultimate treatment.
You sweat out impurities and soak to soften the skin with a body scrub.